[Music]
No Mas was like this movement within the
president and I saw God's change
I watched men change from these hardened
individuals to these open
laughing named remorseless treacherous
lecherous kindless villain home vanishes
Shakespeare asks you to access big
emotions some of the themes are parents
who have let children down
depression anxiety revenge can we be
forgiven for our crimes many wear masks
in prison the beautiful thing was when
you agree to act you're agreeing to put
on another mask and you can only put
that mask on if you take the one that
you've been wearing off
[Music]
what Damien's story proves is that some
of the people who we incarcerate have a
lot to give back to the world if only we
would let them
[Music]